do you remember when you first met he
came to the pet store looking for a job
it was summer after sixth grade s
congratulations on a on a fantastic
movie Sammy this script is so unique and
clever and and I believe if correct me
if I'm wrong this is your first produced
screenplay it is wow you know I'd been
thinking about these these tabloid cases
that you know were so prevalent growing
up in the '90s and then we seem to be in
this Renaissance of
relooking at all of them kind of one by
one and um and I think I thought back to
the the Mary Kern case and and you know
some of these student
teachers um and I I remembered that they
had children and I thought oh they those
children are probably adults now and I
just had this real creepy image of an
empty house with with a couple like this
and that was kind of the the first Spark
of of it that got me really excited I
did what was it about this script that
that stood out and was you know made you
sort of leap at it I was just so taken
with Samy's writing and these characters
that she created but also the questions
she was asking about performance and
identity and truth and whether art could
be a moral um I just was completely
obsessed with all of these
unanswerable questions that she she
raised and and of course these delicious
characters that we we got to play I read
the script that Natalie sent me and of
course as you read it I'm I'm seeing
Natalie R so there's already a center
figure here and I'm imagining Natalie
carrying us through this this film but
it's so true how brilliantly this idea
of dealing with tabloid culture is
separated by 20 some years but what that
does is it creates this space Natalie's
character uh Eliz Elizabeth is elicited
into navigating and chipping away at the
walls that have been erected around this
family and how they survived all these
years but what it really ends up
becoming is a a question about how we
tell stories and what is the cost and
damage associated with tell and the
presumptions of accessing truth but
immediately we started to talk about it
and the way she talked about it reminded
me so much of Julian Moore in her
fearlessness and her interest in in
taking us into places that are not
always comfortable this is I believe is
it your fifth or sixth film with Todd
wow what is the secret to this ongoing
collaboration did you could you have
imagined back all those years shooting
safe that that you'd be this this scorsi
and
dairo I'll take dairo no you're scors
I'm
Nero I'll take that oh my God God I'm
I'm fortunate that he feels that I can
bring his Visions to to life you know
and that he can count on me as a partner
and I'm I'm here for I'm I'm here for
whatever and this was uh this I mean I
was so excited I really was like is this
really happening is this really H are we
really doing this and i' always wanted
to work with Natalie as well and was
such a fan of hers and and and it only
got better meeting her and working with
her you know it's just used a tremendous
creative partner Natalie was able to
pick up um the you know my gestures my
mannerisms and the vocal stuff like in
real time she she managed to do
something that I think was just so
wonderful and so elegant which was as
that as she was as I was being Gracie
and I would you know she I could see her
out of the corner of my eyes copying my
mannerisms but in the most in a way that
Gracie where she felt approved where she
felt where she felt um you know she's
telegraphing this version of of herself
too she wants Elizabeth to see this and
so there's this a tremendous amount of
approbation she gets from watching
somebody you know act like her you said
something Todd that I just love and I've
been stealing it that some roles demand
Discovery and that you know when when
you saw Charles it that was your
experience it's always a wonderful
opportunity when we have something like
really challenging to try to to try to
figure out and we put out a breakdown
and got readings from actors and some
really fine actors and all Korean
American actors um Charles though did
something unlike anybody else he seemed
like he was still encased behind you
know all of these barriers there was it
was so suppressed and so subtle you know
it just distinguished itself it made me
see who Joe was in real time so I sort
of saw the whole film and what and what
Charles had intuited uh at the very
beginning and did you put yourself on
tape originally I did wow yes cuz so
often you do that and you send it off
and you're told to forget about it but I
just how do you forget about this
opportunity well you know when I first
uh got the uh script and the sides I saw
that it was uh Natalie Portman Julian
Moore and Todd Haynes were attached and
doing the project and so I was like what
do I have to
lose and then I got the call and uh to
do another tape and then I flew into New
York City to do a chemistry read with
Julie and Todd and wow up until that
point it was I remember walking out of
that room and thinking this is the best
experience of my career I don't know
despite whatever
happens this is it you know just to work
like that those six weeks leading up to
that moment where I'm standing behind
the audition door and I'm hearing Todd
and Julie whisper and talk about the
scene and just that feeling and then
leading to Savannah where we filmed for
23 days and then meeting Natalie and
just being with them on set oh it's uh
very surreal I'm still like kind of
pinching myself in this moment and I
understand in addition to you know
preparing mentally to to play this
character you really changed yourself
physically just kind of looking at the
history of Joe and everything kind of
the I the different roles he had to take
on that really just uh shaped his
adolescent and uh just kind of that
Arrested Development that was really
buried and repressed deep down inside of
him and just kind of understanding how
that would manifest through this his
physicality and the way that he talked
the way that he walked and moved and and
those were conversations Todd and I had
about uh not so much what Joe would look
like but feel like yeah uh and Sammy
some of my favorite scenes uh are you
wrote These scenes about an actor's
preparation process so knowingly how did
you gain that Insight television actress
who's who really has something to prove
here is you know there is something that
that felt uh comedic about that as our
entry point I I think I just followed
the the natural steps of of what that
would would be sort of gaining
information absorbing you know almost
then getting to this um this Vamp
vampire like level um but I will yeah
that's that felt like a natural way to
for us to keep getting information about
the story did you read that and kind of
go like she nailed it yeah it's like a
documentary we're looking
to you know represent people's hearts
and understand their souls and minds and
how their inner workings But ultimately
also cannibalize ing people's emotions
and the brutality of like using people's
real feelings and real stories as our
raw materials that there's this
really harsh ethical you know Paradox
that that we face when we do what we do
about real people in particular that's
problematic I mean it's it's like
there's no answer to this but it raises
so many incredible questions and I mean
and that's why this Samy's piece is just
infinitely interesting you have this
great script already but actors really
Elevate the story and sometimes know the
character is better than than anyone
else and that's got to make your job all
the easier particularly the way the film
is shot with these extended long takes
that are these SE scenes that take place
in the
mirror that a a tremendous amount of
space is given for the actor to live in
the frame and for us to watch and
observe that interaction between the
actor these are you know ideas came from
great filmmakers like Burgman or even on
the on a very different tone Woody
Allen's Beautiful film Manhattan or or
um the graduate which which again rely
on the kind of restraint for how those
films work visually and cinematically
but those films don't work without the
performances what is it you hope for
from a director when you arrive on a set
point of
view seriously I mean it sounds like
it's it sounds like kind of a silly
thing to say but it's like that's it's
everything it's everything if you don't
have that you can't you can't you can't
do it you know people always ask me you
know what kind of character I want to
play or what kind of story I want to do
next I'm like I don't know like who's
telling the story you know what's the
point of view it's like tell me how
we're looking at it and then I can tell
you what I want to do in it and that's
something that Todd does that's so
spectacular is he always has a very
specific point of view and he
communicates it with everything you know
the way he frames his shots with the
with the time he places his movies in
this is you know this is set you know
somewhat in the past it's not modern day
um with um how he casts it with um with
his language when he writes things it's
all it's all there there's so much
information that I always say that Todd
does all the work for you what Julie is
saying about point of view is is
exactly right but not everyone can
communicate it so clearly so that I mean
Todd was so precise and open with all of
the inspiration and image and tone in a
way that we were all on the same page of
telling the same story in this very
particular tone that he designed so
precisely and then created the emotional
space which is
also important like without that you
don't have the freedom and the courage
to try crazy things that you know lead
to the magic moments um and he he just
gave that that all of those aspects
together and that is not just rare it's
like you it just never happens all of
those elements at once you know it's
it's magic I've never met anyone like
Todd and and I've never worked with
a director like Todd and he's really
changed my life in so many ways as an
actor and uh I discovered my process
with him working on this film and
uh I learned so much from Natalie and
Julie you know and I felt just elevated
every step of the way and just
encouraged and trusted
and so grateful thanks thank you so much
for coming out and thank you all here
thank
you